echemos un vistazo a la reacción general
de la deshidratación de un alcohol para
formar un al que no aquí del lado
izquierdo tenemos nuestro alcohol el
carbono que está unido a lo h es nuestro
carbono alfa y luego el carbono unido a
ese es nuestro carbono beta en este
mecanismo se requiere de un hidrógeno
beta en un momento hablaremos sobre eso
también necesitamos ácido sulfúrico y
hay que calentar para que se lleve a
cabo la reacción también se podría usar
ácido fosfórico en lugar de ácido
sulfúrico a veces resulta mejor para
obtener el producto final del lado
derecho se puede ver que se ha ido el
wache para formar agua en términos de
deshidratación y se formó un doble
enlace entre nuestros carbonos alfa y
beta si a ustedes les gusta hacer
tarjetas para memorizar podrán estas dos
cosas y del otro lado pueden poner a los
productos
ahora veamos cómo es el mecanismo es
decir los pasos en los que ocurre la
reacción
empecemos con nuestro alcohol lo voy a
redibujar por aquí pongámoslo en el
hidrógeno beta
aquí tenemos a nuestro h con dos pares
de electrones solitarios pongamos sus
dos electrones yo sé que el ácido
sulfúrico está presente en esta reacción
y que es un ácido fuerte de brondsted y
lowry dona sus protones al estar en
solución entonces hay protones flotando
alrededor en esta solución dibujaré un
protón h más por aquí la porción de
alcohol de la molécula funcionará como
una base de bronce de lowry aceptará ese
protón entonces uno de estos pares de
electrones formará un enlace con ese
protón diré que será este par de
electrones y atacarán a este productor
se formará un enlace covalente dibujar
el producto de esa reacción ácido base
pongamos nuestro hidrógeno beta por aquí
y el carbono por acá que nos queda bueno
a un par de electrones no les pasó nada
ese par de electrones sigue con el
oxígeno y este otro par forma un enlace
covalente nuevo entre el oxígeno y el
protón aún tenemos este hidrógeno unido
a ese oxígeno queda algo así cuando
calculamos la carga formal en este
oxígeno habíamos dicho que tendríamos
una carga formal más 1 entonces este
oxígeno está cargado positivamente lo
cual no le gusta nada el oxígeno es muy
electro negativo así que ahora quiere
tener más electrones el mejor lugar
donde el oxígeno puede obtener algunos
electrones es este enlace
carbono oxígeno el siguiente paso del
mecanismo es que estos dos electrones se
irán con el átomo de oxígeno
dibujemos el resultado de esto que creen
que pasará aún tenemos este hidrógeno
muy bien dibujará un enlace más derecho
y luego simplemente rompemos este enlace
entre el carbono y el oxígeno y así el
agua se separó nos queda por acá tenemos
un oxígeno unido a dos hidrógenos este
oxígeno que tenía solo un par de
electrones solitarios gana otro par por
el enlace que tenía con el carbono así
que ahora hay agua flotando por ahí esto
generó una nueva carga formal con este
carbono que ahora tiene una carga de más
1 este carbono no está feliz necesita
electrones no tiene un octeto de
electrones a su alrededor entonces el
último paso necesitamos formar un doble
enlace muchos libros dicen que esta
molécula de agua puede funcionar como
una base de bronx de lowry así que
tomará
este productor solo al protón si yo
pongo a mis electrones en este enlace
recuerden uno de estos electrones era
del hidrógeno pero solo el núcleo del
átomo es tomado por la molécula de agua
y se quedan estos dos electrones estos
dos que se moverán para formar el doble
enlace dibujemos a los productos
continuaré por aquí esto formará el
doble enlace entre nuestros dos átomos
de carbono así y luego podemos tener
reacciones ácido base entre el agua y
h2so4 y todo eso hemos formado nuestro
al que no regresemos y tratemos de
seguir a estos electrones un poco mejor
vamos a ver estos electrones con los que
empezamos son los que terminan formando
el doble enlace pongamos a estos
electrones de color azul los siguientes
electrones que vamos a seguir sigamos a
estos de aquí los electrones de este
enlace son los que se unieron a este
oxígeno estos electrones y ahora lo
último que podemos hacer es colorear a
estos electrones estos son los que se
movieron para formar el al que no en
nuestro mecanismo de reacción
este es el mecanismo de la
deshidratación de alcoholes para formar
al que nos observen que en el mecanismo
tenemos un carbono cargado positivamente
al que llamamos carbó catión carbon
catión
en este mecanismo se forma un kart
vocación en otro vídeo hablaremos más
sobre carbó cationes y posibles
rearreglo pero por ahora solo nos
interesa el mecanismo general escribamos
el mecanismo general para una reacción
actual echemos un vistazo al ciclohexano
lo voy a dibujar al ciclo ex zanon
y agregamos ácido sulfúrico podemos
deshidratar esta molécula y perder agua
vamos a pensar en un mecanismo para esto
sabemos que el carbono unido a lo h es
nuestro carbono alfa y este y este son
los carbonos beta
sabemos que cada carbono beta tiene dos
hidrógenos verdad hay dos hidrógenos en
cada uno de estos carbonos entonces
cualquiera de estos hidrógenos puede
participar en el mecanismo pero qué pasa
en este mecanismo bueno podemos hacer
una versión corta en el primer paso
sabemos que hay dos pares de electrones
solitarios en el oxígeno y sabemos que
hay protones flotando en la solución
pongamos nuestros dos pares de
electrones en ese oxígeno y sabemos que
hay protones flotando en la solución
podrá los electrones aquí acá tenemos un
h más podemos protón hará nuestro
alcohol dibujaré el resultado de esto
ahora tenemos un oxígeno unido a todos
hidrógenos y ahora sólo tiene un par de
electrones solitarios esto tendrá una
carga formal positiva ok al oxígeno no
le gusta la carga positiva y hará lo que
pueda para deshacerse de eso entonces
estos electrones se van a ir con el
oxígeno y el agua sal ese es el paso de
la deshidratación y nos ha quedado un
carbó catión aquí este es un kart
vocación y puedo tomar cualquiera de
estos carbonos beta ahora podemos pensar
en la molécula de agua actuando como una
base de brondsted lowry que acepta a
este protón este tomara al hidrógeno lo
que significa que los electrones se
moverán para deshacer esta carga formal
positiva + 1 del carbono y formarán el
alguien entonces el producto final sera
y los senos
este fue un mecanismo rápido veamos otro
ejemplo de lo que llamamos una
eliminación 1 esta vez usaremos una luro
de alquilo veamos si podemos obtener el
mecanismo de reacción es otra
eliminación de 1 aquí tenemos a nuestro
alumno de alquilo que sea brom pondré
sus pares de electrones y lo haremos
reaccionar con etanol pongamos el etanol
también vamos a calentar ok
este alumno de alquilo es llamado un
alumno de alquilo terciario es terciario
porque el carbono que está directamente
unido a nuestro halógeno es este que
está unido a 123 carbonos por eso es
terciario entonces si un alumno de
alquilo terciario reacciona con etanol y
calor por la vía del mecanismo 1 el
primer paso es dejar el grupo se formará
un kart vocación
en el ejercicio anterior el agua salió y
en este ejemplo es el halógeno así que
estos electrones en el enlace entre este
carbono y el bromo se irán junto con el
bromo vamos a poner el mecanismo tenemos
a este bromo que solía tener tres pares
de electrones solitarios a su alrededor
y ahora tiene cuatro pares de electrones
eso genera una carga formal negativa -1
y el grupo metil aún está ahí así que
perdimos el enlace en este carbono el
azul que teníamos a la izquierda este
carbono queda con una carga formal + 1
este es el primer paso del mecanismo la
formación de un kart vocación el bromo
es relativamente estable como grupo
saliente porque ahora tiene la
configuración de un gas noble es una
unión estable así que tenemos esta
situación sabemos que este es el carbono
alfa
tiene el halógeno y sabemos que uno de
estos es nuestro carbono beta ya sea
éste o este no importa sólo le
quitaremos un hidrógeno y nuestra
molécula de etanol actuará como una base
si dibujo la molécula de etanol
el etanol tomará este protón le robará
solo el protón y dejará el par de
electrones con lo que simplemente
formamos un doble enlace para
deshacernos de la carga positiva y
finalmente obtenemos el producto dibujar
el producto de nuestra reacción de
eliminación ahora sabemos que si tengo
un grupo metil en la parte superior
puedo ver que se formará un doble enlace
entre el carbono alfa y el beta un doble
enlace aquí y este no es el único
producto de esta reacción pero por ahora
podemos formar un al que no empezando
con un alumno de alquilo ahora quisiera
hablarles sobre el término
1 eliminación en el primer ejemplo el
grupo que salió fue el agua y en este
caso es el halógeno y luego se forma un
doble enlace esa es la parte de
eliminación por el grupo que entra esta
reacción se convierte en un y molecular
lo que significa que la velocidad de la
red
depende solamente de la concentración de
uno de los reactivos aquí la velocidad
de la reacción solo depende de la
concentración del alumno de alquilo
terciario y por eso se da la formación
del kart vocación el primer paso
determina la velocidad de la reacción el
resto se desarrolla a partir de esa
etapa determinante es la etapa lenta por
lo que depende completamente de la
concentración original de nuestro alumno
de alquilo pero no del alcohol porque el
alcohol no interviene hasta que exista
un kart vocación entonces como la
velocidad sólo depende del allure o del
kilo se dice que es un y molecular 1 y
por eso se llama eliminación